uh so some of you may know this i'm
actually a stand-up comedian which means
i do a fair share of touring which means
i stay in more than my fair share of
hotels i don't know if you guys have
stayed in a hotel recently but they've
started putting up this new sign uh in
the bathrooms we actually have a picture
of the of this sign it says uh hey we it
doesn't say hey
it would be nice if signs were like hey
over here you know anything like
hey fella in the bathroom i got some
tips for ya uh why is the sign from the
30s okay
whatever i say is the show isn't that
weird
isn't that just a weird reality okay so
the sign says parentheses hey
we care about the environment a towel on
the floor means please replace a towel
on the rack means i'll use it again
please be green reuse your towel i don't
know why whenever i see this sign i
always have this weird reaction i feel
like they're trying to get away with
something you know and mask it in
environmental concern so in my mind i
always have this really sassy
automatic reaction i just go
excuse me
you leave the air conditioning running
full blast
in your cavernous lobby all day
and all night
and you want me to be green
how about this
wash my damn towels
you say you care about the environment
yet you have eight tvs constantly
running in that tiny ass gym no one's
using
i watch my ham's house
when i checked in the tv in my room had
been left on for hours just so you could
tell me about the overpriced pan-asian
restaurant in the lobby hey you want me
to be green
where's my name
that's my damn house
my damn towels
you're trying to get all al gore ted
talks on me
yeah you give a ten foot fold out paper
map to any jerk who just wanted to know
where the nearest starbucks is
here's an inconvenient truth wash my
house